♪ ♪
>> Kennedy: WELCOME BACK,
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
VLADIMIR PUTIN GETTING READY FOR
THEIR RUMBLE AT THE HIGH STAKES,
TOMORROW, BITE AND PROMISING TO
HOLD RUSSIA ACCOUNTABLE AND
CONFRONT HOOTON BUT ALL OF A
SUDDEN HIS TOUGH TALK FROM THE
PAST HAS TURNED TO PRAISE, WATCH
FACE BECAUSE YOU KNOW
VLADIMIR PUTIN, YOU THINK HE'S A
KILLER?
>> I DO, HE'S RIGHT, HE'S TOUGH
AND I HAVE FOUND THAT HE IS, AS
THEY SAY WHEN I USED TO PLAY
BALL, A WORTHY ADVERSARY.
>> Kennedy: WHICH ONE IS IT,
RICHARD?
>> Richard: HE IS A WORTHY
ADVERSARY AND ALSO AN
AUTHORITARIAN.
GOING INTO THIS, I THINK WE
TALKED ABOUT, THE MEDIA HAS BEAT
THE STORY TO DEATH ON THE SUMMIT
BUT I DO THINK I'M GIVING A LOT
OF HOPE TO HAVE DIED AND THAT HE
IS GOING TO GET THIS RIGHT, NO
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN ABLE TO GET
THIS RIGHT, MOST PRESIDENTS HAVE
FAILED.
>> Kennedy: ADMINISTRATION
AFTER ADMINISTRATION.
>> Richard: NOBODY CAN GET
THIS RIGHT.
MAYBE HAVING A SINGLE PRESS
CONFERENCE WHERE HOOTON CAN'T
UPSTAGE YOU.
>> Kennedy: OR EMBARRASS
HIMSELF.
>> Richard: WE SAW WITH
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Kennedy: WE SAW WHAT
JOE BIDEN REPEATEDLY IN THE G7.
>> Richard: I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THAT.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT.
>> Greg: THEY ALL LOOK ALIKE,
RIGHT?
>> Richard: I THINK JOE BIDEN
IS GOING TO DO A GREAT JOB, HE'S
SERVED AS A VICE PRESIDENT FOR
EIGHT YEARS, HE HAS A FIRST HAND
SEAT TO WHAT WENT WRONG, WHAT
WENT RIGHT AND I THINK HE HAS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET IT RIGHT.
BY CALLING OUT THE HYBRID
WARFARE WE SEE RUSSIA ENGAGING
IN EASTERN EUROPE.
>> Kennedy: IS GOING TO SAY
"NO, WE DIDN'T DO IT, PROVE IT."
>> Richard: OF COURSE HE'S
GOING TO SAY THAT, THAT'S I
DON'T HAVE A PRESS CONFERENCE
WITH HIM.
>> Kennedy: THERE WERE NOT
HIGH EXPECTATIONS OF FIRST TIME
PRESIDENT TRUMP MET WITH HOOTON,
PEOPLE SAID HE'S A RUSSIAN ASSET
AND PUTIN IS A PUPPET MET HIM AT
PUPPET MASTER.
>> Jesse: I THINK WHAT TRUMP
UNDERSTOOD IT, WHEN IT COMES TO
THESE HIGH STAKES ONE
HIGH-STAKES ONE-ON-ONE SUMMITS,
A LOT OF THIS IS PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIP AND YOU CAN INSULT
THE COUNTRY, INSULT THE LEADER,
THAT MAKES THINGS TOUGH.
IT LOOKS LIKE JOE BIDEN HAS A
LITTLE BIT OF WHAT I CALL
IMPOSTER SYNDROME, I KNOW IT
BECAUSE I HAVE IT, IT'S AN
INSECURE FEELING THAT YOU'RE NOT
WORTHY OF THE JOB YOU HAVE.
I'VE SEEN JOE BIDEN KIND OF
GRAPPLE WITH THE FACT THAT, WAIT
A SECOND, AND THE LEADER OF THE
FREE WORLD HERE AND TWO MONTHS
AGO I CALLED THIS GUY KILLER AND
I'M ON THE EVE OF THE BIG
DIPLOMATIC MEETING, MAYBE I
SHOULD SOFT IN SOFT IN THIS UP.
IT'S ALL HAPPENING IN REAL TIME,
HE SEEMS UNCOMFORTABLE ON THE
WORLD STAGE.
WHAT I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
CARE ABOUT IS NOT SOME DISSIDENT
THAT NO ONE CAN PRONOUNCE HIS
NAME DISAPPEARED OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT, I GET THAT --
>> Greg: THAT'S A CONSPIRACY.
>> Jesse: I GET THAT, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE I THINK THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE CARE ABOUT THE
TAX THAT JACKED THEIR GAS PRICES
UP AND THE HACKS ON BIG BEEF
THAT SCREWED UP THE BARBECUE.
THAT'S WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
CARE ABOUT THE MOST AND YOU WANT
TO SEE THE PRESIDENT CONFRONT
THE LEADER OF RUSSIA ON THOSE
ISSUES AND ACTUALLY DO SOMETHING
AFTERWARDS.
>> Kennedy: THIS IS YOUR
WHEELHOUSE.
WHY NO BILATERAL PRESS
CONFERENCE?
>> Dana: THE WHITE HOUSE
EXPLANATION IS THEY DIDN'T WANT
TO GIVE PUTIN AN INTERNATIONAL
PLATFORM.
YOU GAVE HIM AN INTERNATIONAL
PLATFORM SO I DON'T REALLY BUY
THAT.
I, YOU HAVE TO WONDER IF THEY
THOUGHT THAT IT MIGHT NOT BE
GOOD TO HAVE THEM ON STAGE
TOGETHER.
BECAUSE JOE BIDEN MIGHT CALL HIM
A KILLER -- LIKE BEING A TWITTER
TROLL BUT FACE-TO-FACE HE WOULD
NEVER SAY THAT TO SOMEBODY'S
FACE UNLESS YOU MEAN IT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY ARE GOING
TO BE FOR FOUR AND A HALF HOURS,
4-5 HOURS, WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO
TALK ABOUT FOR 4-5 HOURS, THAT'S
A REALLY LONG TIME.
I THINK THEY WILL COME OUT OF IT
WAS SOME SORT OF THING WHERE
THEY CAN AGREE ON CLIMATE CHANGE
SOMETHING OR OTHER AND THE MEDIA
WILL SWOON AND EVERYONE WILL BE
SO PLEASED BUT HE HAS TO COME
OUT OF IT WAS SOMETHING ON THE
RANSOMWARE.
HE HAS TO BECAUSE IT'S AFFECTING
PEOPLE AND THERE ARE AMERICANS
BEING HELD UNJUSTLY, THAT ISSUE,
THERE ARE AMERICANS BEING HELD
UNJUSTLY.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A PRISONER
SWAP, WE WILL SEE IF THAT
HAPPENS.
BEFORE I THINK THE BIG STORY WE
LEARNED IS THAT JESSE WATTERS
HAS IMPOSTER SYNDROME.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THAT IS -- I'M
LEAVING TOMORROW WITH THAT
MONOLOGUE.
YOU HAVE IMPOSTER SYNDROME OR
YOU'RE FAKING THAT YOU HAVE
IMPOSTER SYNDROME.
LOOK, HERE'S THE PROBLEM, THE
PROBLEM WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
YOU DON'T KNOW WHERE HE'S COMING
FROM AND YOU DON'T KNOW WHERE
HE'S GOING MUCH LIKE HIMSELF AND
WITH THE CONTRAST IS YOU ALWAYS
KNEW WHERE DONALD TRUMP WAS
COMING FROM, TWO YEARS, AMERICA
FIRST.
I DON'T EVEN NO, A LOT OF STUFF
TRUMP DID THAT NOW DOESN'T SEEM
AS IMPULSIVE AS IT WAS BEFORE
THAT MAYBE HE ACTUALLY KNEW WHAT
HE WAS DOING LIKE HOW TO BE
SOCIALLY AMENABLE WITH DICTATORS
AND BEHIND THE SCENES THEM AND
WORK SOMETHING OUT.
I THINK ONE LESSON IS, WE CAN
ENDURE AND EVEN SURVIVED NOT
BECAUSE OF OUR LEADERSHIP A IN
SPITE OF OUR LEADERSHIP BECAUSE
WE PUT PEOPLE IN THIS JOB THAT
CLEARLY HE'S NOT UP TO IT, BIDEN
CAN BUMBLE THROUGH THE THIS
THING WITH THESE LONG,
FRIGHTENING PAUSES AND WE ALL DO
SIT THERE QUIETLY AND GO, WHAT'S
GOING ON?
THAT PAUSE WENT ON FOREVER AND
MEANWHILE GOD FORBID TRUMP HELD
HIS GLASS OF WATER WITH TWO
HANDS ARE SHUFFLED DOWN THAT
SLIPPERY RAMP AND EVERYBODY WENT
BALLISTIC BUT BIDEN ASKED LIKE
MR. MAGOO ON MAGIC MUSHROOMS AND
WE ALL HAD TO SAY, YOU KNOW,
NOTHING TO SEE HERE.
IS THERE A BASEBALL GAME ON?
IT'S BORING.
>> Kennedy: ARE THEY GOING TO
ASK FOR TRANSCRIPTS LIKE THEY
DID IN THE CALLS WITH PUTIN AND
TRUMP?
>> Greg: THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION